[Music]
no
go
[Music]
no
go
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
hey what's up
everybody uh first off can you hear me
and I assume you can see me I can see
myself uh but can you hear me okay give
me a yes in the comments if you can hear
me hello hello looks like we have quite
a few people here today which is
awesome all
right
sounds okay great thank you so much um
okay what's up Milan great to see you
here uh Dan 550 great to see you here uh
we already have a few members of the
collective who have joined uh which I
always love seeing you guys here on this
q&as uh to maybe help answer some
questions or just give your your take on
on your experience so far we've only
been into it for a few days so and we
really haven't even gotten started yet
uh so for those of you who don't know um
I am here today my name is Cameron um
I'm the guy who founded motion science
this channel you're watching um if you
don't know and I've been kind of
promoting it everywhere uh I've I'm I've
started something new called the
collective and the collective is a
mentorship SL Community um is how I'm
kind of describing it right now and uh
that means that the collective is here
to support you and to help your your
progress uh to streamline your progress
and speed up your progress in learning
motion design as well as pivoting from a
beginner or mid-level artist to A high
level artist um and having a career
whether that's freelancing or full-time
or whatever that may be um that's what
the collective is in a nutshell um the
reason I started the collective uh is
because
I see so many motion designers out there
who who struggle uh to really get
somewhere in motion design like maybe
you've taken a course maybe you've taken
many courses right and you go through
these courses and they're structured and
they're there's an a road for you to
follow right a road map for you to
follow and you learn a lot in these
courses and then you finish the course
and you kind of say well now what what
do I do now like what's the next step uh
do I take another course
uh do I go try to find a job do I go
freelance am I not good enough yet you
know should I keep learning like how
long should it take for me to learn
there's so many questions right and
there A lot of times we're in isolation
because of the world today uh there's
not a lot of community for lack of a
better term and maybe in certain cities
you live in there there are more
opportunities for Community like if you
live in a a big City like in the US like
New York City or or Los Angeles or
Chicago um there's some like you know
motion graphic groups and things like
that but anywhere else it's pretty
challenging to have um any type of
community unless it's online and I've
also seen that there's been online
communities uh around for a few years
but I see a lot of them kind of come and
go right or they're not very active
there's some people in there at first
and they're asking questions they're
helping and then they kind of just die
off because there's not a lot there's no
real reason
uh to keep the community vibrant and
active uh so that's my that was my
challenge I'm like how can I help the
motion design Community uh overcome this
isolation and this not knowing uh
there's so many questions what can I do
so I started the collective right and
we're in open registration right now uh
it's open till Friday uh then I close
the registration so the reason that
people have asked me like is this open
all the time can I join any time no
because I want it to it's open now so if
you want to join join and then I'm
closing registration until
2024 uh because I want it to really feel
like a tight-knit family and I want you
I want everyone in there to be really
comfortable with everyone and that means
that people aren't just coming and going
um and there's not somebody new showing
up every other day or every week um and
it's just it's a really positive
supportive
community and you're going to know
everyone that's in there and then next
time it opens up in 2024 there'll be
another group that'll come in and and so
on and so forth so um that's kind of
what the community is and why I started
it um it also kind of stems and I'm just
giving you a little bit of background
here it also stems and if you have any
questions please put them in the in the
chat box I will answer them I promise um
but this also stems from if you're
familiar with my stylecraft course uh I
launched stylecraft several years ago uh
in its initial State now the stylecraft
that is out today uh is is has been
redone two times over so it's not the
original course but when I launched it
originally uh and maybe there's a person
or two on this chat on this call here
that was part of that group but we used
to have a community um mentoring aspect
to the course and um people loved it now
over the years that kind Community kind
of I kind of changed things and it got
less and less and less and it finally
went away and I I realized that people
loved that aspect of it so much that I
needed to bring something back and so
again I was inspired by that to bring
back that kind of element uh to motion
science and it's the collective so
that's what it is and some of you may be
wondering like well if I take a course
and there's a community with that course
and maybe there's there's some Tas that
help me with that course like what's
different from that versus what the the
collective is and what's different is
you're getting access to me on a daily
basis is
um I'm in the community every single day
and I'm there answering questions and
giving feedback um but also every single
week uh we're going live with zoom calls
and I'm teaching workshops I'm doing
live q&as uh where we're face to face uh
I am doing um discussions overall
discussions meetups uh we're
also um let's see what else are we doing
we're doing
workshops q&as discussions and I'm
totally blinking on the fourth one now
um but basically we do one a week and um
it's just it's really exciting to me so
the workshops are more creative based uh
the discussions are all around you know
career and freelancing and what's the
next steps and things like that and
maybe we will do some workshops that are
uh not so creative based but maybe go in
the direction of career stuff but I love
the creativ aspect of motion design
obviously and so I wanted to continue
that here inside the collective um so
that's just a little bit um about it you
you have access to me every day uh on a
weekly basis we're on live calls um you
have access to a pro you have access to
other Pro motion designers in the
community as well uh because I know
several people who have joined already
who have been around motion science uh
for a long time and they are super
awesome super experienced create amazing
work and we're all here it's not just me
you know giving feedback and mentoring
and blah blah blah it's it's the whole
community so I want everyone to
contribute um so that's another thing if
you join the collective uh you I want
you to contribute I don't want people
showing up in the community and not you
know giving feedback and not giving
their two cents and not asking questions
uh you have to be active in the
community now if you decide to show up
on a zoom call and you don't want to
turn your camera on that's okay you know
I get it there's times where I don't
want to have my camera on either so um
sorry my dog is barking away in the
background
there um okay so let's get to some
questions here um we've got some people
looking forward to the collective
awesome yeah I know some of you guys
have joined already which is great super
exciting um hello from the
Ukraine awesome I'm terrible with
pronouncing names so I don't want to say
your name wrong um but those of you who
join the collective you know we'll get
get to know each other a lot better so
and that's the thing too with motion
science you know some of my my members
have been around for weeks months years
and we I know who they are I still have
people that email me like hey I've been
around I took stylecraft years ago and
I'm like I know exactly who you are I
remember because there's a lot of
one-on-one personal uh connection uh
within every emotion science course and
especially the collective uh what's up
Brian uh hello from Chicago What's Up
Chicago I heard it was kind of chilly
there the other day I heard some friends
were there um it's not chilly here it's
hot
here uh John JW what's
up John would like to learn more about
the coaching uh which I think I kind of
talked about that a little bit here uh
John maybe if you have additional
questions about coaching please ask in
the chat I'd love to answer
specifics um but how the coaching works
is on a day-to-day basis like I said I
am in the community if you post
something that you need immediate
feedback on I'm there to give some
feedback it's not going to be as
in-depth as when I go live on a zoom
call um but when we do go live on on
Zoom calls like the that was the fourth
thing critiques of of your portfolio and
your work so we have a call uh where we
could do an hour Zoom call and um if
there's there's work that you want
critiqued you submit it into the
community the community sees it everyone
is welcome to give their feedback on it
I will also give my detailed feedback on
it uh in the zoom call so um this is
something we've done for years in the
stylecraft community that people love uh
where we get into the nitty-gritty you
know actually going frame by frame and
doing critiques on that work uh and it's
super helpful right whether or not it's
your work or it's somebody else's work
it's a chance for you to see on any
piece of work okay this works and this
doesn't and why is that right and it's a
way again of just speeding up your
progress because when you realize these
things like these little subtleties um
or reasons for for things happening uh
it just it it it amplifies your your
progress um and is very very helpful so
um there's that type of coaching uh
there's General coaching where we just
have open discussions uh where you just
show up and you ask your questions on
specifics whether that's creative
whether that's career-based um and I
here to answer questions the rest of the
community is here to answer questions we
have people in the community right now
now who uh work for companies doing
motion design we have people who have no
job yet um and are just starting out we
have people who uh dream of having a job
that don't yet we have Freelancers uh we
have Freelancers who are uh veterans in
the industry we also have people who
have just recently stepped into
freelancing uh we have U people at least
one person maybe I think two people um
that have their own agencies
um within the collective so there's a a
wide variety of people here uh to pull
from so it's not again it's not just me
um I just want to be your guide I'm not
the guru right I do know a lot right
I've been doing this for 25 years I have
a lot of experience but so do other
people within the collective and that's
what it's all about it's it's about
taking everyone's um knowledge and
pulling from that and getting the
answers that we need so um the only time
that as of right now that that we're not
face Toof face on our our weekly calls
is when I do the Creative Workshop um
I've decided to start this first
Workshop next week is the first one um
without everyone's face now there is a
chat box there um but so I can go
through this whole creative process and
not get really distracted and it doesn't
end up taking you know three hours to do
a project um it's going to be more of
just me explain the process and if
people have questions I'll answer those
as I'm going through it um but if that
if that if it works to have people on on
there you know chatting with me as I'm
working through it we we'll try that too
but for now that one I just want to keep
it it's a chat only it's me showing a
creative uh Workshop which I have some
really one fun ones planned um and it's
these are workshops that uh beginners
can do intermediate level users can can
work on as well and the more advanced
people um will find a lot of good
nuggets in this these workshops as well
so I'm really excited about the
workshops like the creative is what
really uh jazzes me up and gets me
excited about uh motion design so I've
got some good ones
planned um but John let me know if you
have any more specifics on the
coaching uh junkyard Carnival yo what is
up uh cannibal cannibal hi from
France what's up France I love
France
Milan John is is all clear okay
great
um what's up
Mo Mo I'm hoping to see you in the
community in the uh in the collective I
know you haven't joined yet but
hopefully and if if it's the right time
for you we'll see you in there if not
then maybe next time U but MO is a
veteran of uh the motion science
community and always has a lot to offer
and mo is uh fairly new to
freelancing
and I think is doing pretty well in
freelancing um let's see junkyard
Carnival have any suggestions or tips
for
moonlighters uh that have full-time gigs
but side hustle for other companies on
re more rewarding exposures to
work um yeah so my first tip for um I
wonder if I can add yeah there we
go so my my biggest tip for a
moonlighter is to be transparent with
your client um and I don't know if
you're if that's an issue or not
junkyard Carnival but when we Moonlight
for those of you who don't know what
that is um that means that you have a
full-time job maybe in motion design
maybe it's something completely
different but you are freelancing uh at
night and on the
weekends uh in motion design and uh it's
a great way to get experience it's a
great way to make extra money um the
biggest thing with Moonlighting though
is that you do want to be transparent
with your client and that means hey
client um just letting you know I do
have a full-time day job um but I'm
willing to I'm able to work on your
project at you know from 6: PM till
midnight Monday through Friday I'm
available on weekends as well um you
know the deadline's super important uh
and we will will hit that deadline but
uh it's just being transparent with them
because the the last thing you want is
your client you know texting calling
emailing at 12:00 on a Wednesday saying
like we got to talk right now there's a
fire we got to put it out or whatever
and you're at your day job and you can't
talk so just be completely transparent
your client will appreciate that it's
all about
transparency um in terms
of rewarding work I mean that's just you
know seeking that out now when I started
um
Moonlighting I was doing a lot of
projects that I was doing it for mostly
for the money and I was trying to build
up reserves to go freelancing full-time
um but I was also doing it for
the the practice of working with clients
um because I didn't I had never I'd
worked with clients in my day job doing
motion design but I wasn't working
really one-on-one um with a client so it
was a great experience doing that um and
it started off gosh I can't even
remember I I moonlighted for maybe six
months to probably a year but for the
first four to six months I was doing
these crappy jobs um that would never
see my reel um it was just more about
the ex you know just making the money to
to build up my savings account um but I
kept hustling hustling hustling and
before I knew it I was getting
jobs um doing like the MTV Video Music
Awards um some HBO Sopranos stuff back
in the
day that would go on my demo real now
when I took those on it got super crazy
because I was working from like 6:00
p.m. till 4: 5:00 in the morning
sometimes and then going to sleep for an
hour and then going to my day job and I
I only sustained that for a couple
months got super sick and then end up
leaving my job and went freelance at
that point but it I mean it will if you
if you continue to build my biggest
thing was building my Reel with with
personal work even though I was getting
paid to do these other projects they
weren't good enough to put them my reel
right to attract my ideal client so I
was doing personal work and putting that
personal work into a reel and building a
reel and constantly updating my reel and
sending it out right to clients that I
wanted to work with like prologue films
right which is how I got the MTV Video
Music Awards so I sent out that reel and
eventually and it had tons of personal
work on it and they liked what they saw
and they hired me and gave me a chance
and then it just it turns into the cycle
so then all of a sudden you're doing
work for clients that are you know
awesome awesome looking work your reels
getting updated you're getting paid and
then the next person seeing you who's
willing to pay you to do the same type
of super creative work and it just it's
an endless cycle but a lot of times you
have to create personal work um I used
to call it spec work but I confused a
lot of people because a lot of people
con consider spec work like work that
you do for free for a client and I don't
believe in that like I don't believe in
doing work for free in the hopes that
it'll lead to something else because 99%
of the time it doesn't um so yeah just
be transparent with your client continue
to do personal work when you can and um
you know I really had to hustle to make
to to work on client work and to build
personal work at the same time um but
that that's the best way to do
it
[Music]
um ilent motion I hope I'm pronouncing
that right by CR Williams looking to
this community as a motivation to the
personal work I concept but never create
to expand my work beyond the company I
work for okay cool um what what's your
name in the in the collective if I'm
assuming you've already joined so I just
want to make sure I know who I'm talking
to and there goes my dog again um
looking this community as a motivation
to do the personal work I concept but
never create so that's a great reason to
join the collective I mean there you go
there's the workshops there's the
creative workshops um in fact I have one
the workshop we're doing next week is a
is a challenge and that's another part
of the collective that I didn't mention
is there's creative challenges and
there's a leaderboard uh built into this
community and it's really fun it's not
you know I'm not doing these challenges
to say oh I'm better than you or this
guy's better than you or whatever it's
not that it's it's just about uh the
challenges are there to get you
motivated to do things um to to do the
work to ask the questions whatever U
there's all different types of
challenges and um so next week we're
doing a workshop on uh one of our first
big challenges it's it's a mo design
piece U but I'm really excited about
that but then the next Workshop after
that uh it's called the magic formula
and it's already
scheduled and it's a it's a really fun
Workshop that's going to teach you
basically like seven steps if you were
to do all of these seven things uh in
any project it will teach you how to
make a highlevel project every single
time um I almost turned it into a course
but I thought why not make it into a a
really awesome Workshop instead inside
the collective so um it'll be in motion
that will be one for you to definitely
to check out and then of course with
q&as and discussions um that's a great
place to get you know direction as well
uh for creating personal work that um
can expand your abilities and your skill
set you know we have discussions I think
we have discussion coming up soon about
uh trending topics like what is working
today in motion design what isn't right
like what effects are are really in what
styles are really in um things like that
so lots of great
discussions uh Milan are we going to be
working on Creative brief together
um well so Milan did some one-on-one
coaching with me and had a lot of
success with it which is awesome uh we
worked a lot with creative briefs
um yeah there's going to be creative
brief challenges I would say and these
are things that you can bring up uh in
the different coaching sessions like hey
you know I'm I'm working on this
creative brief uh a lot of times with
the workshops I'll show you how I would
take a creative brief and and I'll do a
project and then you'll be challenged to
create something similar and you'll have
a creative brief and you'll uh go and do
that and then a week later you may have
questions so you'll come back to one of
our our Zoom calls with with questions
and yes it's it's an open time for you
to ask to get help all that so
uh Mo how many people have joined so far
and do you have a person limit uh no I
do not have a person limit at this point
um because we're in the founding stage
we're going to see what happens um my
goal is as I said to be in this
community every single day and this is
like my priority moving forward um I I
know that this thing is going to be
super successful and so many people are
going to join um and I my goal is to be
in this thing every single day and
helping as many people as possible and
if that means like we have a feature
within the collective um called meetups
and I can literally hit a button and go
live um other people can go live at this
point too like if you want to meet up
with your buddies in the group and just
have a little chitchat you guys can all
go live together there's ability to do
that as well um
but I want to spend as much time as
possible in this group um on a daily
basis and the more people I have in
there the better because Mo you've seen
it in other communities we've had like
people kind of come and go right like
you've got things to to to work with
right now you've got questions right now
you're going to be there you're going to
be super active for a week or two a
month or two whatever and then you're
going to kind of go quiet for a while
because maybe you get super busy with a
project you're working on and you don't
need the collective so much you're going
to step back but you're still going to
be a member and then other people are
going to come in so like the more people
we have in here the more Synergy there
is um the more activity there is um and
the more we can all learn from each
other so I want to bring in as many
people as possible um right
now um I don't actually know how many
people have joined at this point um I'm
I was in there just before this call I'm
responding to people so um there's a
decent amount of people in there for
sure and it's open through Friday so um
I expect a lot more people to join uh
before Friday so um but we've got some
really cool people so far uh exciting
and I would love to see you in their MO
and it's a different platform Mo it's
it's actually back on our kajabi
platform uh the last group that Mo was
in was on a different platform I brought
it all back together and uh super
excited about
it uh Clive hi I'm in the UK what time
are the weekly meetups so right now um
that's a question I'm getting a lot um
right now the meetups are scheduled for
Tuesdays and
Wednesdays uh 12:00 p.m. Eastern I
believe so that'd be what 6 or 7 o'clock
I think 600 p.m. your time um I do hold
the right to um reserve the right to
change days and times based on if we if
I find that a lot of people can't do a
certain day or time we're going to maybe
tweak some things cu because this is the
first group um but for now I have eight
sessions scheduled out uh for the next
eight weeks and you can go in once you
join you can go in you can select which
one you want to be a part of and um
register and it puts it on your calendar
and sends you reminders we also have an
app um that sends you notifications like
Hey we're going live uh you signed up
for this you know you should be there so
um right now Tuesdays and wedes Tuesdays
and Wednesdays 12:00 p.m. eastern time
uh Clive also sent me an a message prior
to this that I sold um and Clive you
were asking about an apple um I think it
was a Mac
Mini and I saw the specs on the Mac Mini
it was an M2 Pro chip uh you're asking
if that's enough for After Effects it
definitely is uh the only thing is it
comes with 16 gigs of RAM I saw and that
is the minimum requirement for after
effect effects uh if it's possible to
upgrade the RAM I would um but I have an
M1 chip uh that does awesome with After
Effects and I think it's got 16 gigs of
RAM as well it's just when you get into
these little bit more um project intense
intense projects um with lots of layers
and effects it'll slow down a little bit
but the M2 Chip is an awesome chip the
silicone chips from Apple um After
Effects runs amazing on them so um it's
a great computer that you work asking
about
Julia
um are you going to focus on both design
and animation 100% 100% um so many
motion designers know how to animate and
so many lack the design side is what I
my experience has been with my students
uh so I love to focus on the design side
I also love to focus on uh the finishing
effects that we can use to make the
design look even that much better if
you've ever taken the stylecraft course
you've seen a lot of that um but yeah
100% I mean we're also focusing on the
animation side um but I feel like
there's so much information out there
for for animation and there's not a
whole lot for the design side um even I
have a lot of graphic designers who join
my courses and um give me really
positive feedback on the design side of
motion design that I teach so um yeah
we're going to focus on both it's it's
so awesome so excited because we're
focusing on the the motion design side
the the design the animation um but
we're also focusing on the career side
and the freelancing and so it's just
this this you know Melting Pot of of
Awesomeness for motion designers uh that
I'm super jazzed
about Brian said it was 102 last week
yeah it's 100 or 102 right now down here
in South Florida
uh it's great to see your excitement I
appreciate that I appreciate that hey
Earl what's going on Earl's been a
motion science member for a while I'd
love to see you in the collective Earl I
hope to see you
there uh Mo I got one small gig randomly
and I'm trying to figure out what's next
and how does this come up in the
collective 100% these are great
questions guys guys and these are great
questions I love it um yeah what's next
we all wonder that I even if you've
taken every single course that I've
created and I've got a lot of them right
over at motion science got a lot of
courses even if you've taken courses
from from other people um you still have
questions right because you don't have
any kind of mentorship any type of like
Community yes there's Facebook groups
and yes there's slack groups I got a a
message from someone yesterday I can't
remember who it was I'm getting getting
a lot of messages lately um saying that
their slack group is just kind of dead
um it happens all the time right or the
community the Facebook communities and
no I'm not ripping on these but what I
see is a lot of people just posting
their stuff saying hey look at this cool
and then they they're gone they
disappear and there's no like real like
hey like you should this is cool but
maybe you should try this to improve and
and blah blah blah and so there's so
many questions um Mo for you
specifically
um you could say you know you know a lot
you know a lot about design you know a
lot about motion you have a very uh
Unique Style that you've developed
through stylecraft that I've watched and
um I know that you're you're new into
freelancing and I know you got that one
gig uh for it was a music artist I think
right or a record
label um but I'm sure you have a lot of
questions about what you should do next
how you should find that that next gig
and that's one of our discussions coming
up like what's working right like where
are people finding freelance jobs right
now right who's hiring what's the best
way is it LinkedIn should we going to
LinkedIn uh should we be on upwork you
know sometimes upwork Milan who I was
just talking about Milan's had some
experience with upwork uh Milan can fill
you in on that right I didn't used to
believe in upw workk things have changed
but It's Tricky right uh LinkedIn has
powerful job search abilities now um
it's also about your network right
there's so many gig you can find from
knowing the right people um people reach
out to me now I don't get it a lot and I
think as the collective grows um I think
there's more potential for me to get uh
job opportunities but I get emails
pretty much on a weekly basis at least
one or two saying like hey can you can
you refer me to somebody um that could
do this this job for me this is what I'm
needing and um I have referred referred
a number of jobs out I've helped some
people get full-time careers so um 100%
what's next how all
that ilent motion is not there yet well
I hope you are soon I hope you are soon
I think you're talking about joining the
the collective I hope to see
you um yeah John I know you love
Creative briefs I think even so so
talking about things from from years
past I remember John asking me if I
would build a course or some type of
product around just creating creative
briefs for people and I remember that
John uh it was a great idea and it's
what I do a lot of in my one-on-one
coaching which I don't offer very often
um but this is something that will be
part of the
collective part of our
challenges um Amed is real enough to get
hired or must get four full pieces all
you need is a reel that's it um a reel
is your calling card in motion design so
um the thing with a reel is that you
don't want to mislead a potential client
with like a piece on a reel that isn't
fully yours um if you did one little
minuscule part of a reel or I mean a
piece and you put on your reel then you
need to you need to call that out and
say well hey in this big piece I
actually just animated this character or
whatever it may be or I designed this
thing um but your real is everything um
it took me three reels three demo reals
to go from Zero to Hero as I like to say
uh my first well by real three I was in
the big leagues uh doing stuff and most
of my real was personal work it was at
least 70 80% personal work um so I would
just work my butt off and make pieces
that I wanted to make and I made pieces
of types of projects that I wanted to do
and those went on my real and those
attracted those types of clients to me
um so you want to put work out there
that you want to to get back
yourself so you don't need full pieces
um it's always nice to have a full piece
if somebody wants to go more deep into
your
portfolio um but no my experience you
just need a
real oh thanks Tim I'm not an after
effect Pro but I've gotten out of
camera's teachings to integrate Advanced
or even basic Graphics into my media has
been invaluable really up to my
understanding and game yeah so Tim
votech Guru uh is an awesome awesome
audio
dude uh who does voiceover work um who
sets up sound sound booths and and this
is why he's why I have this microphone
um and um I appreciate that that nice
comment Tim thank you so
much
um ahed is collective for excuse me is
collective for cinematic motion
designers or for all motion designers
well you know I say it's for all um my
specialty is Cinematic motion design now
like if you're looking for someone to
help you with like character animation
and like straight up Vector um that's
not me but that's not to say there's
other members of the community that
aren't into that um I've had a couple
students in the past who have come in
doing vector stuff and they they kind of
were a little different like I'm talking
about shiny you know flat Vector
straight up colors uh they would add
like texture and stuff to their vectors
so they had a distinct look
um but I don't like you know cinematic
motion design is a pretty broad term in
my world
um so I you know the community the
collective is definitely for every type
of motion designer you know if you're
here then that tells me that you're
jealous
with some of the stuff you're seeing for
motion science right you're like you
like the style that you're seeing maybe
you're interested in in moving forward
with that style and kind of Shifting
your style into that I don't know but if
you're here there's some type of
Interest with the visuals that you're
seeing and it may be a good fit for
you um I also want to mention based on
that comment that I do have a 30-day uh
refund guarantee on the collective so if
you join and within the first 30 days
um you don't really like like what
you're seeing all you have to do is send
me an email and I'll refund your money
no big deal so um do keep in mind that
this is like literally brand new so the
comments have finally started rolling
but for I opened this up Thursday of
last week and I had one person join
immediately and it's like you know he's
kind of sitting there like what do I do
there's nothing here um but I mean
there's there's videos of me explaining
everything and now the comments are
really starting to roll in I'm starting
to see everybody uh one of our first
challenges is to introduce yourself and
post a picture of yourself uh so that we
can know kind of who you are and we've
got some really interesting stories so
far um John I've now done a
real but looking to keep developing my
craft so my style doesn't become too
formula
formulaic
formul hope Collective can help with
that
definitely again you're you're seeing my
stuff you're seeing other people's work
uh in fact going back to a Mod's
question um someone recently joined um
who did some work
for a sports team in um Los Angeles and
he had a very Vector type of style um
and he was super excited to be in the
collective so that shows you that there
are multiple Styles happening within the
collective um which which is great you
know to help push you and kind of keep
evolving um one of the things I've been
known for in my freelance career is I'm
um a generalist meaning I can do a lot
of different styles uh when needed now a
lot of the stuff created through motion
science is because that's what really
jazzes me is those style that style and
um I I want to create as much as that as
possible but I can create a lot of
styles in fact we have a workshop coming
up in
I can't remember if it's ooc October or
November um that's a collage style which
is going back to the first version of
stylecraft I had um had some really cool
collage style stuff it's something that
pushes me out of my comfort zone um and
I'm super excited about that
one yeah John I hope to see you um in
the
collective uh Earl not sure if this is
the space to ask but since the society
has been uh xed out is this the next
stage cuz my subscription is still going
sorry for asking the page is dead so I'm
not sure yeah or also um send me an
email after this to remind me um
basically if you had the society
membership that's going to carry over to
this one so I have to do a couple things
internally inside the platform to get
you in there but I've had a lot of
emails from people uh saying hey like
here I am because I've been so busy with
this launch
uh please send me an email and I will
get you switched
over uh Brian will will the class cover
anything that resembles what touch
designer can do um I mean off the top
you know I'm not familiar with touch I
mean I know what a touch designer is um
I know that it's
very oh what's the right word it's just
got like I always think of like a lot of
geometric patterns and things like that
with touch designer love what it can do
there's a few artists that I follow uh
that absolutely love what they do with
touch designer
um so I we're not going to get into
specifics no about touch designer um but
remember a lot of things I teach can be
applied to different softwares right
like yes I use after effects yes I use
Cinema 4D light sometimes but the
principles a lot of times what I'm
teaching can be applied to any software
perfect example of this is the magic
formula Workshop that we're doing
um in a month it teaches you the teaches
you these principles that can be applied
to Cinema 4D that can be applied to
touch designer I'm sure uh blender
Unreal Engine uh it it doesn't matter
it's just it's things that you need to
be aware of in ways of thinking it's
it's a way of thinking yes there's step
by step of how we're going to create
this in After Effects um by adding key
frames here and these type of effects
over the top but it's a way of thinking
it's a creative way of thinking that
kind of expands your mind to like here's
what can actually be done in motion
design doesn't matter what software it
is my title sequence design feels pretty
dull how do I get to the level of my
favorite ones on Netflix HBO Etc well um
great question Michael uh take
stylecraft join the collective that's I
would say um that's a lot of stuff that
I teach I constantly get asked hey did
you work on this Netflix title did you
work on this HBO like literally those
two I get asked all the time because
it's it's very similar to the stuff I
teach um which I call cinematic motion
design right we teach a lot of stuff
with title design um I have a lot of
background in uh TV like show
opens um promos show closes things like
that um and the process I teach you you
can ask any of my former students uh
they will tell you that I teach the
processes that make it look like what
you see on Netflix on HBO so I would
highly encourage you Michael to join the
collective uh join stylecraft if you can
I would also look at my creative
workshops um Beyond title design the
course we have is awesome those are all
going to teach you higher level ways of
thinking higher level ways of doing
uh in After Effects uh to make things
that look awesome like
that uh 3D what are some good resources
to become a master in title sequence
design uh I just named off several um I
I highly encourage you to check out
motion science courses uh the
collective um yeah and this is a little
tangent here just because you're joining
the collective doesn't mean that you
shouldn't still be doing courses right
um I've got people who are joining who
are taking stylecraft uh who have are
also doing the collective at the same
time because they want feedback on their
stylecraft work um they want to learn
these ways of doing things in stylecraft
they also want to get um newer ways of
learning things as well in the
collective and getting feedback and and
all that stuff and asking questions so
uh good resource become a master
entitled sequence title sequence design
is motion
science
lots of love from Barat what's up BV
thank
you yes Milan is getting started in
freelancing
awesome yeah 3D my my question is
basically like Michael yeah I hope I
answer that for
you
um sirh Hill hopefully I'm pronouncing
that correctly I need to put together a
really cool portfolio with trendy work
but I want to focus on really stylish
and Powerful work so that I can go
freelance and do what I really like the
collective
absolutely um it's not sir Hill it's
also not about just joining what's
trendy um it's doing the work that
really creatively fulfills you um kind
of gets you jazzed up right it
creatively fulfills your soul
and that whatever that is man like that
if you create it you can create income
from that that art so there's you're not
the only one in the world who's going to
be into that right you're going to find
clients that if you put that work out
there to the world your clients will
find you if you put it in the right
places the clients will find you you'll
find them and you'll get paid to create
this stuff so um there is a time and a
place for trendiness and that's some of
our discussions but at the same time
like find the work that like I said that
creative fills you and that you're
really into right whether that's like
grunge or or vector based or um highly
textured or you know it's all about the
motion whatever it may be um
infographics title
sequences um logo
animations focus on that build your
reel send that reel out to the world and
start building your freelance that way
and yes the collective is here to help
you with that
100% uh is vertical smartphone oriented
work welcomed absolutely I mean like
today you know a good buddy of mine he
that's all he does now his social
vertical videos and he says it's quite
it's quite different um he used to do
all Network TV stuff he did the Olympics
lots of t TV shows you've probably seen
and now he's doing all vertical social
videos and we actually have uh someone
in the community um I think it was Phil
who just posted a vertical piece that he
did looking for feedback so absolutely
any format doesn't have to be widescreen
horizontal um you bet Earl you bet
what's up
Santos thanks for being
here um
Brian if I join stylecraft will I also
be in the collective uh no there are two
separate things so um back in the day I
used to have a community with stylecraft
but it was also you know four times the
five times the price um so I removed
that to make stylecraft more affordable
for people so you can just get the CH
content and follow the path that I lay
out for you um but the collective is
separate so if you want the community if
you want everything we're talking about
here today definitely join the
Collective get stylecraft I still
recommend styc I mean Starcraft is my
signature
course um if you know what after effects
stylecraft is where it's at the
collective is right there with it these
are the two that I I would tell everyone
to take stylecraft and the
collective oh great comment Earl thank
you I would love to see this Earl there
is stuff in his classes that help me on
a widen Kennedy project or should I say
projects really good stuff thank you so
much I would love to like please post
this in the community I I love to see
what you guys create and I don't see it
enough it's like when I when you guys do
post the work I love it um I love to see
what where the fruits of my labor have
paid off with your work and it's it's so
awesome
um okay got it Brian answered your
question perfect sir Hill don't like
vector cinematography is the closest to
me thank you you're you
bet uh where can I find links to the
collective and motion science courses so
write this down motion science. TV uh
these are the courses and then
the collective um that is specifically
for the collective motion science. TV is
going to have the rest of the
courses um and then
stylecraft is right
there
uh Gary your courses are great thank you
thank you Gary I appreciate
that hopefully I'll see you in the
collective
Gary um I'm just going to reiterate
again the collective registration is
open right now it's open until Friday um
and after that I'm closing down
registration and it won't be open again
until
2024 um that is the plan and that is
people ask why can't I join it because I
don't I want this to be a super
tight-knit community of of motion
designers visual creators and it is
super important to me that we don't have
people coming and going
um so that's why I'm closing
registration down also if you decide the
collective is not right for you I do
have a 30-day uh refund so you you have
30 days to try it out see how you like
it and I should mention after 30 days
let's say you're in it for a few months
and for some reason it's just not
working out for you or maybe you know
life happens I don't know um you can
cancel at any time so there's no like
long-term commitment um I've got a
monthly plan and I've got an annual plan
so the annual plan obviously you pay
you're in it for a year and when it
comes around that year every news unless
you decide not to renew it that's
totally fine annual plan it's month-to
Monon you do save a little bit of money
if you go
annual um also I'm going to tell you I'm
including a
bonus um for joining and that is a a 30
minute uh one-on-one strategy session
with me and that's a zoom call with me
um it's 30 minutes so that we can kind
of like lay out a game plan for you um
it's just a way for for me just to just
it's it's just you and me and we can
quickly figure out what it is that maybe
you should be focusing on uh what are
your strengths what are your weaknesses
where you should be heading um and it'll
just help you with your Collective um
experience so that's why I'm including
that as well um so once you join uh we
will be scheduling those out here in the
coming
weeks uh Brian when does registration
for St stcraft end uh Starcraft
registration is open all the time so I
used to have an open and close
registration period for Starcraft but uh
you can join at
anytime uh let's see here Gary says I
had one question do you teach how to
integrate film editing in Premier Final
Cut to use an after effects to animate
Vector type Graphics over it
um not really
um I talk a little bit
about Premiere Pro to After Effects
workflows I do talk about that in After
Effects Academy 1 which is part of the
after effects Academy
series
um and there are some other parts of
like some of our courses like Beyond
title
design um and maybe a couple of the
workshops where we do touch on like
using Premier Pro or Final Cut to to
create
animatics um and then push those into
After Effects kind of like the workflow
that that I use and some of the other
designers use um that's very common but
in terms of
like creating specific graphics and then
going back to Premiere Pro no I don't
really focus on that now the stuff that
you do learn through motion
science um it does apply to to Vector
type Graphics like you know creating
supers and and logos and things like
that that can easily be imported into
Premiere Pro um to use so I have had
several um editors I've had a lot of
video editors actually that have come in
to kind of learn what you're talking
about Gary um and have a lot of success
with that uh Christopher being one I
recently just thought of um he has his
own little agency now and he now he's
able to actually offer he was just video
editing now he offers video editing uh
and motion design and 3D he's actually
moved into that as
well but you know it's just it's a
matter of like
creating graphics with Alpha channels
and then bringing those into premere
Pro hopefully that
helps and maybe you know like if I get
enough feedback inside the collective
that people want to learn more about
that kind of stuff that's obviously
something that I would be willing to
teach in a workshop uh because like I
said I did do I've done a lot of
Graphics super Graphics like you're
talking about for like shows on
NBC uh I've done some stuff for the
Olympics um the WWE
Network um God I could probably go on
and on and on if I looked at my list so
I've done a lot of work like that um
where I actually built the graphics and
sent them to an editor and he would just
plug him into the
edit uh John can I switch from monthly
to annual at any point once fully on
board uh yeah we can it's not a super
easy process what we' do John is you'd
be on monthly and we'd have to cancel
your subscription um and then reactivate
it as an annual membership but you would
just have to reach out hello motion
science. TV and we'll get you set up to
do
that uh Michael I see a lot of title
sequences with nine style frames is
there a structure to this like a three
act or or am I looking too much into it
um well you know in my experience it's
always been between 6 and 12 style
frames nine is a nice number in between
those um that's just kind of like a a a
standard for a piece but it also really
depends Michael on how long um the piece
is that we're creating style frames for
so if we're doing a 30- second
commercial you know maybe we don't need
nine style frames to to fully show that
maybe it's just you know three or four
um if it's a two-minute piece we may
need 9 to 12 style frames uh it just
really depends now some some motion
designers will work a different way but
the way I work and the way a lot of
people I know work is we will do six to
12 style frames right um and we'll lay
it out and we'll show kind of beginning
middle end of what the piece looks like
but it's not like a laid
out frame for frame of what the the
motion is
and then what we'll do is if if there's
several motion designers who work on the
style frames and the style frames are
there to create a look and feel right
and I teach some of this stuff in
stylecraft um but once that look and
feel is
established if there was maybe three
different motion designers who did style
frames the client is going to pick one
set of style frames okay and once we've
decided on maybe there's some revisions
that happen once those style frames are
decided on then we may go into a process
called uh boarding b o a r d i n g and
boarding is where we take those style
frames and we kind of fill in the gaps
so if it's the end if a if a set of
style frames there's nine frames and the
and the ninth style frame is the logo
sitting there there may be three frames
for that in frame that are boarded out
to show exactly here's what the logo
does maybe it rotates and it's
transitioning and it's moving and
there's particles going and things like
that then it gets much more into the
details but in terms of style frames
we're just trying to establish the look
and feel of a project um so there's not
a set amount of frames 6 to 12 is kind
of the you know General
approach IL beant motion have to get
back to work thanks Cameron see you soon
I'll be signing up awes
awesome Gary thank you for the
explanation Cameron much appreciated you
are
welcome uh John thanks for the info
camera you are
welcome uh Earl's got some great advice
there yeah great advice Earl and this is
like the kind of stuff that happens in
the community in the in the collective
right it's not just me having to answer
the questions for you because I do
something one way and then there's other
designers in there that do it a
different way and we're all there to
learn from each other and expand on our
our knowledge and our abilities so I'm
just there to guide you I'm not the guru
I'm just going to guide you I'm going to
introduce you to the right people that
can answer the questions if I
can't and it's
awesome oh okay well we had a lot of
comments
today um I'm probably going to wrap this
up unless I get any more
questions uh here at the last couple
minutes so many awesome questions uh I
do hope to see a lot of you in the
collective as I said there's
um what three more days to join and then
I'm shutting down
registration and that's it you can't
join again until 2024 um I'm also going
to say that um in 2024 there's going to
be an Initiation fee uh I think it's
going to be 147 and that's just to get
you set up to join the collective so if
you join now um you're getting that
Initiation fee waved which is another
awesome bonus um you're getting a 30
minute strategy session with me which is
awesome I also have a little thing in
there uh if you buy the collective you
can actually upgrade your 30-minute
session to an hour which I've seen a lot
of people do it's a really good deal um
so we can just have a one-on-one
strategy session you and
me um what else I I also want to tell
you that because this is the
founding um registration period for the
collective um that there is a chance
that when I open up registration in
2024 um that the cost will be higher um
I don't know that for sure
yet going to kind of see how this this
goes um but this is the founding rate um
this that's because you know you're
coming into this brand new we're going
to we're going to work out the bugs but
the it's it's set up it's there's people
in there it's going great so far um next
week we're starting our first Workshop
our first live Zoom um I also want to
say if you can't be there live we've got
some time zone issues uh or you have
other commitments um everything is
recorded every live Zoom session is
recorded uh so you can go back and we
have a Video Vault and you can go back
and you can watch those recordings at
any time uh typically the recordings
will be posted within 24 hours um so
there's a Video Vault Library there that
you can go back and reference any call
that you missed if you have a question
that needs a very thorough explanation
from me on camera you can ask that
question ahead of time in the community
if you're not able to be on the call and
I will answer that call for you answer
that question for you um if you have
work that you want feedback on
um I will as long as you post in the
community in the feedback section I will
give you feedback uh in
that Zoom call and you can go back and
watch the recording at any
time um what else do I want to say let
me double check here really quickly and
just make sure
but there's nothing
else um yeah Earl says I'm trying to
drop camera work and just edit and do
and edit and just do M graph which I
have a lot of people like that too I
like like I said I have graphic
designers who want to move out of just
static design into motion design um I've
got uh video
producers uh Shooters video Shooters as
well that want to move into motion
design um I've got some really
interesting I'm not going to name them
out I've got some really interesting
other careers completely outside of
design motion design that want to
transition into being a motion designer
that are joining the collective so uh
it's it's fun to see where everyone's
coming
from um
let's see make sure I got everything
covered here we talked about the
coaching the workshops Community
challenges um weekly Zoom
calls reviews and
critiques y live q&as there's going to
be plenty of live
q&as um we've got the monthly rate the
annual
rate one-on-one strategy session
bonus
30-day uh refund policy so try it out
for 30 days if it's not working just
send me an email I'll give you your
money back no big
deal okay well uh that's going to do it
for me for uh today's live Q&A thank you
everyone for being here thank you for
asking amazing questions I appreciate
each and every one of you uh you guys
are awesome and uh I I really hope to
see uh as many of you as possible in the
collective if the timing's right we're
here we're waiting for you we hope to
see you in the collective uh everyone
just keep on creating keep doing your
thing and uh I will talk to you guys
hopefully sooner than later everyone
have a great day
bye